delphine bergeron alias d'elfes et
illustratrice judiciaire c'est à travers
ses dessins que nous avons découvert
l'apparence physique de quelques-uns des
criminels qui ont marqué l'histoire
judiciaire du pays
chaque fois qu'il ya des fugitifs des
criminels qui recherchent comme acquis
il faut qu'on le pende viven pourquoi on
peut cela les dessiner lors des procès
de guy turcotte luc aro compagne au tas
ou des shafia
ces décès ont témoigné de la justice en
action et harvey lequel l'or en train de
dessiner
servez plus qu'une fois puis ça ça me
jean-paul souvent c'est dans des moments
super dramatique super très sous la
moitié des gens dans sa halle de toute
façon port ils l'ont souvent que
quelques secondes durant les
comparutions pour apercevoir l'accusé et
le dessine et le plus fidèlement
possible souvent ne soit pas non plus
quand qu'on les reconnaisse qu on voit
leur visage même si les caméras sont
toujours interdites dans la majorité des
salles d'audience la province le métier
d'illustrateur judiciaire est en voie de
disparition
je fais plus à temps plein c'est devenu
impossible de gagner ma vie
seulement en faisant ce c est relié à la
crise immédiat et médias sont plus les
mêmes que dans les années 90 on avait
quand même plus large palette de surfer
juste référence aux hommes allô police
photo police l'instant c'est des gens
qui achetaient beaucoup de médecins la
sphère scorpions le procès de maurice
mom boucher avant de se tourner vers la
caricature y fait des milliers de
dessins judiciaire avant facebook avant
les réseaux sociaux si tu avais pas une
photo directement des individus
concernés par la ferte avait pas de
photos pas en doute quand j'en faisais
beaucoup je rentrais dans une salle
d'audience une minute j'arrivais
ressortir à l'extérieur et faire le
personnage sans même le regarder fait
que ça occasionnait des problèmes
judiciaires
même s'ils ne peuvent plus en vivre il
reste attaché à ce métier y récemment
repris ses crayons lors de la tuerie le
soir de l'halloween à québec et d'elfes
entend bien passer ses vieux jours à
fréquenter les palais de justice
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses si j'ai
appris sur le site